I think that one out of every tube were
more likely to out of every three people
in here that our co-founder are not
purebred actual entrepreneurs and are
making a mistake in starting a company
and let me explain what I mean by that
and I know that's a razz and it's like a
tough thing to say but it leads to a
bigger conversation of self-awareness
I'm not saying it like I'm cool I am you
aren't I'm saying that we are living
through a narrative time right now where
over the last half decade
entrepreneurship has been glorified to
an extreme where everybody just feels
that they're entitled and should and
it's attractive to start a company and
what they're really doing is not putting
themselves in the best position to
succeed and are wasting time hurting
their brand losing people's money doing
a lot of things that won't help them and
stunting their own growth because they
would have been incredible number twos
threes fours and five you have a lot of
people that are built DNA wise and skill
wise and have studied and went through
school and have been formed and have
trained to be unbelievable consultants
at Bain & McKinsey and other places have
a great career and then get involved in
entrepreneurial ventures where they can
leverage the monies they made and invest
and things of that nature who are
starting consumer apps out the gate and
have no [ __ ] clue how to be a true
bred entrepreneur because they don't the
stomach to deal when the market says go
[ __ ] yourself right and so that's a
problem and more importantly that
problem bless you and that problem is
about to rear its head because there's a
lot of people in this room know you know
I know and I'm sure others as I look
around as money crunches start to happen
bless you
I think that a lot of I think that we've
just lived through the golden era of
people saying they were entrepreneurs
but what they were was they were
operators that were building machines
aka companies that were built for
financial arbitrage people have been
building startups that are predicated on
raising the next round you've been
building your company for user growth to
raise your next round you're not
building a company and so look and this
is not me staying on my high horse right
before she hits the fan in 2009 and Jeff
you know that's better anybody in the
room in 2009 at the height of my career
bless you as I listen I get it there's
anything else we really love to sneeze
anybody you do I'm super into it it
gives me like a weird high you to what
is that okay let's figure it out later
um at the height of my career by the way
just for context I got much more set
investing but my first three investments
were Facebook Twitter and Tumblr so I'm
in that I'm friends with zux brands
would Travis remover on you know crush
it just came out and it's killing
everything's going great and in the
middle and this is 2009 it's all about
to happen I'm at the height I'm one of
the 20 most follow people on Twitter and
Twitter is just starting to matter me
and my brothers start a client service
business a client service business
something that is really at the lowest
end of Admiral Admiral start ups right
just a 8-times ebody business like a not
super sexy like eat [ __ ] from clients
all day right and so so this is not me
post gaming or Monday Morning
Quarterback this is me telling you what
I've been doing with my behavior while
all this was available to me
nobody could arranged more money than me
in 2009 and 10 I'm right there at the
top of it all that I had already built a
65 million dollar business I'm at the
top of my game and I took four steps
back including being ridiculed and made
fun of by my internet famous friends
I went build vaynermedia AJ even to it
you know didn't love it because all his
friends were millionaires on paper
joining path and you know and Digg and
reddit and all this stuff and
we kind of struggled with it for the
first two years because it was hard it
was a big humble pie that I had to eat I
to go into brand manager meetings and it
was crazy for where I was in my career
but I was self aware to know what I was
capable of building that would be
successful and in the 48 months since
I've really run it it's been alive for
six years I've grown that company from
30 to 650 employees from 3 to 100
million dollars in revenue right and not
passed for revenue of media like we do
100 million right and in current 2.5 to
3 time revenue valuations for agencies
it's a 250 to 300 million dollar
valuation with a business that's going
to kick 17 million dollars in profit
this year that me and my brother and my
partner right and that one you can clap
because that was real execution in the
face of a lot of sexy other things to do
in the face of and I wasn't a kid I'd
already made it and I still went
practical the level of practicality the
level of self-awareness the level of
patience the level of humility the level
of empathy to the market and gratitude
for your opportunities and the level of
understanding what's happening in the
macro and micro economic climate in our
space is [ __ ] and it's about to hit the
fan and so I highly recommend if you
take anything from my talk tonight I
would ask you to do one thing start the
process of becoming much more honest
with yourself it will help you make much
better decisions and it will help you in
the long run it may not taste this fun
or as glamorous in the short term but it
will put you in a much better position
because something I've learned as this
has become more obvious to me in the
last year as I started doing the
askgaryvee show and started giving more
eq more self-awareness more those kind
of talks and as I wrote this book I
started realizing huh I started asking
more questions and what because I was so
isolated from Silicon Valley when I
built my web 1.0 company started talking
to a lot of my 40 and 50 year old
friends at these companies at GE at
Procter & Gamble at Fox News at Turner
at Toyota at all my big clients fortune
fighters and you know what I realized
holy [ __ ] a lot of these 40 and 50 year
old friends of mine they were all worth
million
dollars in 1999 on paper in Silicon
Valley because the next wave of what we
just lived through is a lot of people
getting jobs and so you can either right
now with my advice if you believe me for
the three of you in here you can either
take your business and start becoming
practical with it and try to build a
business that makes money instead of
trying to position it for your next
round or you could start dusting off
your resume and trying to get the best
first jobs that are about to become
available as all this [ __ ] is going to
hit the fan because I promise you it is
and so I'm not here to doomsday I'm here
to go practical and the level of
practicality in our space is grossly
missing and so I hope you heed that now
at the same token let me go crazy
optimistic on you impact this is why
this is the most interesting time in my
career in parallel this is not 1999 and
2000 when the internet wasn't ready and
wasn't that scale and it wasn't just yet
there yet this is at a time where you
can build something that can go from 0
to 100 million users in 18 months
because we're at full scale ret mobile
revolution so with all this talk of me
telling you like you suck and shits
about there the fan in parallel there
may be three people in here that are
poised because I promise you
Airbnb and uber and companies like that
and even potentially hopefully I'm an
investor drizzly and things like that
these are the previews they're not
anomalies so in parallel to 98% Joker
land fake entrepreneur everybody thinks
they're one in parallel there's going to
be an enormous amount of companies in
next 24 months maybe more than in the
last 24 months that go on to become the
slacks and the you burrs of the world
because there's so much opportunity
because because and reasons right
software is absolutely eating up the
world and every single thing that we are
as humans are inefficient at will be
closed the gap by technology so it's an
interesting place you know I have a lot
of MEP clothes a very large fund and
probably a hundred million dollar fund
it's gonna be funny for me to deploy
capital during this because I know so
many people are poser
but I also know that there's going to be
so many opportunities for big businesses
to be built and so I think we're sitting
in a very interesting time and I think
the reason I decided to put the word
self-awareness is one of the key title
parts of this book is I think we start
having a very important conversation of
self-awareness because there is another
part and I'll open up QA to this
self-awareness thing the dirty little
secret about our world that is not being
talked enough about is depression and
suicide my friends in a world where
everybody is cheering when you get a
Series A or B check which means you've
just given up a piece of your business
by the way and in a world where
everybody's going to crush it and
everybody's going to win there are a lot
of people especially when they were
built to be good students and be good
number fours and 7s that when they go to
be a1 and after a life full of winning
because they understood that system they
go into the actual marketplace no more
rich friends and families and
connections in private school and good
universities no real [ __ ] the [ __ ]
game nobody gives a [ __ ] who your dad is
that game when they go to that game and
they lose it's tough and if we keep
telling everybody that it's so easy to
do it and if we don't start talking
about that the entry level to be in the
top 1% earners in America is only
$400,000 a year and they used the word
only because nobody here is even in the
mindset of million-dollar or bust right
we need to start having proper
conversations if we don't start talking
about 95 plus percent of your startups
will fail if we don't do that then we're
really doing disservice to the people
that join the greatest thing in the
world in my opinion which is capitalism
entrepreneurship market dynamics what
makes this place great and so I'm not
saying this because I want to sit on my
high horse I'm saying this right here
and saying we have to start having much
much much more honest conversations in
our space because we're doing nobody any
good I had a meeting the other day where
a person I invested in lost his company
it's gone it's over
they'll be shutting down next 15 days he
had one last-ditch effort on a down
round didn't happen it's over by the way
get ready to read a shitload articles
about down rounds this summer anyway
over dead right
and he goes I you know I'm up I guess I
mean I have a sad face during the
meeting because it's a sad event right
like it's over and he sees that I'm sad
because Oh Gary don't worry like I'll be
fine I learned a lot through this
process I said [ __ ] I'm worried
about the hundred fifty thousand dollars
you lost of mine not worried about you
like I gave you money and you [ __ ]
lost like this notion that this is play
money or who cares
the BCS don't care like I [ __ ] care I
came from zip I lived in a studio
apartment with eight family members the
size of this stage when I write a check
it hurts I want you to win I want you to
do something I'm not worried about your
education process of the entrepreneurial
journey [ __ ]
seriously that meeting caught me off
guard
he seems like we are broken we are not
having the right conversations and I'm
trying to give everybody in this room
anybody that watches my show anybody
that reads my book a six to 12 month
headstart that is going to pay dividends
for them if they either choose to do one
of two things look in the mirror and
recognize and figure out if they have
the luxury of having supper wareness is
this maybe not what they're about and
number two if it is to figure out how
that business makes money in the next
six minutes thank you
my man I'm gonna repeat these questions
we know have a second mic to run do we
okay all right so you talked a lot about
Facebook ads but being cheapest thing
out there not the cheapest thing just
the best value yes
what do you think about Instagram as I
never follow up to that your teleview on
Instagram yes what do you think about
like long yeah you know I'm content
so two things Instagram not working the
way I thought it was going to work today
nine months ago is the stunning most
stunning thing that's happening in tech
for me the fact that Facebook's back-end
isn't accurately working on deploying
Instagram ads is stunning like what I
mean by that is when I target 18 to 22
year old african-american males on a
piece of content on Instagram 54 year
old old white women shouldn't be showing
up in my comments but they are and that
doesn't happen on Facebook and it is on
Instagram so Instagram is not working
yet like punchline it's not consistently
working and they're still trying to
because I think they're trying to figure
out their cadence on how much they want
to deploy there right because it's such
a golden goose but I think Instagram the
reason I asked for people to review my
book not on Amazon definitely not on
Twitter definitely not on their blog the
reason I asked everybody to who would do
it
to review my book in long-form on
Instagram with a picture and 25
sentences on Instagram is two reasons
one day training attention from an
organic standpoint the number one
platform in the world right now is
Instagram so any if you have 300
followers across the board the best
chance for me to get people to know what
I want from you is on Instagram it has
the best depth from organic reach go
ahead I see one a schism so from
warm content Pam point you found people
engaging more yes so that's part two we
do tons of testing at vaynermedia at
scale we know that long-form posts on
Facebook and Instagram are over indexing
short letter posts right now yet every
single person on earth tells you that's
not true go home tonight for kicks and
giggles if you have a Facebook fan page
put a picture up and write 12 sentences
and copy watch what happens to your
organic reach so like to me bro the
truth is when you day trade attention no
romance for example I know that 7 minute
videos on Facebook dominate but
everybody tells you to write short
30-second clips because it's micro
content and social media and dadadada
my man we live in a world of headline
readers somebody reads one person say
something and it becomes the momentum we
don't have practitioners the reason I
maintain my personal brand is because
I'm better at social media than anybody
that works for me and we're the best
social media agency in the world yes
Jeff a lot of investors talk about user
acquisition versus Billy's business
of course because the BC game is
predicated on having one unicorn drive
your entire fund and if you can get one
company to really crush it because they
became 200 million users you pay for
your whole thing but the 99 other
companies that you tell the view that go
out of business building a business that
makes money is usually a good idea when
you're building a business I'm into it I
think it's a good strategy yes sir
yeah Oh am i Qasim thank you brother
you'll run around yeah thank you Paul
so you're talking about the pressure yes
I wonder how you do like service out
there wait so what sounds you have the
self-doubt do I
I don't but that's because my mother
hyperbolized the [ __ ] out of me and over
like built my self-esteem in business I
don't have doubt in swimming huge down I
suck at swimming
I'm scared I don't but I only don't in a
very specific and narrow reason and
again it's fun to have you Jeff here
Jeff is somebody I worked with very
early on when we started a nerd I just
stay in my lane like this is back to
self-awareness I stay in my lane I'm a
Salesman I'm a business builder I've
done it my whole life I was an F student
at 13 and 14 my friend's parents told my
friends not to hang out with me because
I was a loser I'm more successful than
my entire graduating class combined like
like this is because the market doesn't
understand that people don't get it you
have to double down on your strengths
and you have to punt your weaknesses in
America there's billions of dollars made
on selling you how to fix the things
that you're not good at it's a huge
mistake you need to figure out who you
are and go all-in that's what I did and
so when you talk about business or
marketing when you talk about the New
York Jets and when you talk about wine
I've got nothing but bravado everything
else you should see me sitting around
dinner tables right now talking about
politics the level of humility and the
level of listening you wouldn't expect
from me because that's not how you're
used to consuming me I'm loud and proud
because I only stay in my lane pay very
close attention I've got nine years of
content on the internet now maybe a
little bit more I've stayed very very
very narrow for me it's lucky the reason
I've been able to kind of grow is my
narrow thing is consumer behavior which
I can deploy against anything so my
narrow thing happens to be quite wide
which allows me to play it allows me be
a good investor it allows me to run
businesses it allows to be to be a
personal brick-like it allows me to do
things but I don't waver from that you
know I don't talk about building product
I've been around starters Mahalo I don't
talk about product I'm pretty good at UI
UX all my I mean F Williams spend and
and David Carr from tumblr they always
like give me good daps behind the scenes
that I'm good at it cuz it's a little
consumer B it's consumer behavioral kind
of so I have good feels I said know how
to lay out my liquor store and that's
how I did well in commerce early on I
just think about all I do is deploy
empathy at scale I'm I mean I'm an
empathy machine that's what I do so so
on the flip side for the people that do
have self-doubt that I feel like I'm the
most extreme purebred entrepreneur I'm
not the wrong person house I'm just a
Nordstrom we're here and I think the
more you have self-doubt is the further
away you are from being a purebred
number one to run a company like
everybody knows that vaynermedia is a
moldable dictatorship right like you can
sell me you just better [ __ ] bring it
cuz I've got [ __ ] ideas you know so I
don't yearn at all for but what that
makes me think is this goes back to
self-awareness maybe you need a
co-founder maybe need to bring in a
secondary since you've already built
something a 20% co-founder if you're
yearning for that then you shouldn't
listen to Gary Vee saying [ __ ]
co-founder or give a [ __ ] I'm a dictator
usually like no no this is what I'm
feeling and this is what I need and who
cares what anybody says about giving if
the only things I do that make no sense
to people on paper I gave me a 50% of
vaynermedia when we started it I had all
the leverage I was 11 years older I got
us all the clients I was to social media
guy I did everything and he had 50% of
business because I knew that's what felt
right in the energy of our brother ship
so I make decisions all the time I sold
I sold Steven Ross owner the Miami
Dolphins related real estate a 30% share
of vaynermedia three and a half years
ago when I knew I was building the
business from 3 to 100 million in a
heartbeat because I want to buy the New
York Jets and so I left tens of
dollars on the table to be in the
ecosystem of the NFL family like I make
decisions all the time they're not
predicated on money so if you feel in
your heart if that was the question you
decided to ask me you should probably
bring in a real co-founder that has
minority interest and who cares if
everybody told you that it was a bad
deal that you gave her 20% it's a great
deal for you because you know what you
need
way too many people in this room
listening to the market or the five tips
or somebody else's advice that did it
nobody's done it the way I did it and
I'm not listening to anybody about it
everybody asked me who's your mentors no
one myself me and we're not and maybe
I'm too far and I respect that I know
what that sounds like if you've never
heard me I'd be like I'm not confused
that there's a percent of people in you
never like but this guy he's got a huge
[ __ ] ego I get it but I know that a
lot of people aren't doing any of what I
just did in that rant and I'd like you
to do a little more of it questions
let's get the guy Mike nice running boy
good form alright great hon so you're
obviously fantastic consumer behavior
understanding how the consumers thinking
art into the consumer but the consumers
totally special right so you've got to
be ready into that you got to be ready
to every day where they're going how do
that's good for a system it's only for
me it's all gut and then I put data
against it to prove me right or wrong
that's what I do I build vaynermedia to
scale me vaynermedia was built to build
the machine I call it machine it's
people the the organizational scale of
me so I intuitively feel like something
was happening with snapchat in the
summer and then I deployed people the
math nerds she's and he's in my
organization that love math that don't
have intuitive DNA that don't like EQ
that don't like people but boy they
[ __ ] love numbers and then I have
them double check and call my [ __ ]
but I move before they come back because
it's worth it for me to lose because if
I'm right which I've been right enough
that I want to keep going the upsides
incredible in the first-mover land grab
of this stuff because it is a market
place and they do move and they move
fast
they move real fast you just wake up and
it's over like I build my brand on
Twitter I was at the top of the heap top
I'm devastated that that's the one that
kind of faded off from attention but
I've written articles two and half years
ago about my concerns about this you
know like it was happening I can taste
it back to be an actual practitioner I
knew that when I had 50,000 followers on
Twitter and said follow my boy me a
thousand people would do it and then I
knew today with my 1.2 million if I said
follow my boy follow my girl Susan like
49 would oh this is not good you know
like I could just you know taste it
because it's all guys ah the level of
disrespect that I have for impressions
and all that stuff this is about
attention I'm not day trading
impressions I can get your impressions
all you want 1 cent YouTube you want a
million views on every YouTube video you
you you can do I can get it for you
right now
one cent I'm not a pre-roll let's do it
10,000 bucks good all day say you're
[ __ ] Casey nice tat you know so like
you know I think that people don't get
it I don't I think that people don't get
it and honestly very honestly as I get
older he left like uh Laura moved like
I'm I'm getting more confident because
as I've gone higher up the ranks and now
hang out with fortune 500 CEOs and I've
watched you know my homies become the
most respected business people in the
world
I'm starting to realize like oh [ __ ]
maybe I'm too humble maybe that really
got gifted maybe I'm [ __ ] LeBron like
I really like I really know what's going
on I mean I know what's going like I
know VR is going to happen and I know a
lot of these C's are going to lose a
shitload of money because they're
betting on consumer VR which is 20 years
away but it but I'm betting on b2b VR
like crazy I'm I'm learning everything I
can about what Facebook Apple and Google
and Amazon think about VR and I'm going
backwards I'm investing VR sound I
didn't even know if your sound existed
but I know the thesis I know the pattern
recognition and other [ __ ] plays out yes
darling
sorry about that my man let me give it
to her the mic you stay there basically
back in crunching your numbers you you
talk a little bit about how you know all
this information and data Alice Organa's
Twitter and all these other place you
may research reports and you had a team
build models on that is that how do you
know all that information and what's
your source no I don't and it's really
just like read online know you like this
I think you're gonna like this and
you'll see why I don't read research
works first of all I was never smart
enough or educated to even know chitt
like that existed in my 20s as I got
into my mid-30s and understood there was
[ __ ] like Forrester and this time the
other thing once I realized who was
doing that work I became less interested
in it because these were people that I
like especially when social media
reporting started happening I'm like
that guy works for Forrester this is
[ __ ] because I knew I knew you know I
knew who so here's what I do you're
gonna find this wild I consume almost no
media period like when I tell you none
it's the scariest thing when people ask
me what do you read where do you get
like I don't read anything all I do all
day is watch people at scale on
platforms so what I mean by that I mean
that I'm basically consuming people's
actions on social networks across the
web so what I do for a living is I'll go
to Hershey Kisses Facebook page and read
every single thing that a normal human
being does I go to Twitter and look at
for four hours look at everything and on
that scale now where I have so much
inbound I'm watching their behaviors and
their reactions to miles my own stuff
and then I'm watching I'm watching
exactly how people are responding right
now to Kate Hudson's snapchat stories
right or what people are doing with Jake
Paul on musically from junior high
behavior and then I'm projecting what I
intuitively think is behavior that ages
up from the teens to mainstream aka why
I loved Facebook okay why I'm so bullish
on snapchat I know this maps to 40 and
50 year olds or let me rephrase I really
think I know and I think it will
and so what I'm really doing is watching
people like for example I can't you know
I love to travel more than any other
reason just really watching what people
do on their phone at airports literally
watch that scale people stop going to
Hudson use and buy things and just going
in their Instagram feed right so what
I'm doing is I'm making pretty quick
judgments you know I'm married my wife
four minutes into our first date and we
met on JDate so like I mean blind four
minutes in we were married within a year
best decision in my life hands down not
even close so I'm intuitive right like
seven minutes into the Internet I was on
a bulletin board I'm like I'm gonna
start a wine store on the Internet I
didn't even have uneven know what the
internet was so I definitely Chuck jump
quickly because but the way I'm doing my
decision-making is watching people it's
why I'm so scared for the death of
Twitter and why I'm so excited to then
invest in the next Twitter because the
watercooler of society is not going away
without Twitter there's nowhere to talk
about the presidential debate not
seamlessly it's harder on Instagram it's
harder on Facebook for us to do what we
like to do there so shame on them for
not evolving the product to keep
people's attention and never fully be
explained to normals you know but for me
it would be devastating because I can't
just use it because it never went to
Facebook scale so I need that and I just
do simple stuff like other things that
people don't think about when I opened
an office in Chattanooga Tennessee
everybody's like why the banner media
open an office agender this is it
because there's two different Americas
there's a very different America between
Boston New York LA and San Francisco and
Chattanooga Tennessee so I forced myself
into pockets there but it's mainly just
watching like I like I'm not basically
I'm listening 24/7 365 I'm listening to
the questions that are being asked here
it's why I started it's why I'm branding
myself as an ask me questions because
I'm getting double benefit I'm bringing
you value and I'm learning from where
the wave of questions are going so
basically my entire being is predicated
on listening which [ __ ] with people
because I'm such a loudmouth and they
think I'm always talking it's but I'm
I repeat what I talked about how to find
self-awareness yes the poor thank you
thank you for that glad I put my picture
on the book um bought that one so I in
that article I talk I've been trying to
so I'm not back to the last question I
really appreciate you asking that I have
a lot of shortcomings I'm not like I
didn't go to school for anthropology I
don't I don't technically know the
pillars of the of what's taught or
widely accepted around human behavior I
don't know if it's accepted in society
that self-awareness actually i weirdly
asked you guys like is self-awareness
being talked about is something that
people think is teachable I mean there's
some people shaking yeah so here's what
I know I'm not sure I definitely think
it's a DNA thing however I gave my
at-bat in that article to how to figure
it out and here's how it goes I think
you need to take the 7 for 8 to 9
closest people in your life closest in a
couple of different circles find that
inner circle and go on a crazy journey
where you literally spend a week or a
month actually making them comfortable
for the next meeting which is giving
them permission to tell you the truth
the people that know you the best and
love you the most are not going to tell
you the truth on the shortcomings which
is the key to the conversation you know
the reason I oftentimes give very blunt
answers and Q&A is that people are
always surprised by is I think I'm
bringing them value I'm trying to tell
them what I think is the situation and I
don't like you know what's ironic you'd
find this funny in public settings I'm
quite a straight shooter in private
settings I've only now gotten to a place
where I'm doing a better job with my
employees by deploying critical feedback
because I used to not like confrontation
so I'm crippled by confrontation like
crippled by it which would be funny
because there's more people and more
cameras I'm quite combative yet in real
life when I run my business my biggest
shortcoming was because I didn't want to
give
Chris a negative review I would never do
it and then I would sandbag him out of
nowhere he'd be fired with not knowing
how it happened I did terrible job as
the operator of Wine Library and I would
actually give my brother AJ a lot of
credit because it was even though he's
11 years younger to me he was better at
it when we started Boehner and I didn't
want him to be better at something than
me so I got competitive and I got good
at it so like I'm not even joking that's
what happened like it came from but you
know all my good stuff comes from this
negative competitive I want to kill
everybody kind of place so I anyway um I
think you have to make the people
closest to you safe to give you real
feedback and and I really think that I
just I it's so obvious now I feel old
and wise oh I've always felt that but
now with 20 years under my belt it is
just so obvious to me who's winning and
who's losing and it's the people that
understand themselves first that are
winning and are not worried about what
others say and can get into that safe
place you know it's funny when it comes
to business and careers and
entrepreneurship we have these lofty
visions that we don't have for us
athletically or in the arts like you
know like people very quickly realize
they're not Kobe or Beyonce but for some
reason everybody thinks that they can
build a million-dollar business when the
data shows you that it's for so few like
I've been hot on this new $400,000 a
year thing I don't think most people
know it the 1% the most competitive best
market in the world of all humans
America and that's true this is the
purest form of capitalism period I think
China is incredible but coming from a
communist country and studying it
there's play of things that we don't
talk about to why we check can get so
big it's not America sucks doesn't go to
Barack and say yo hook it up kill
snapchat so you know
so so we're not even America about that
so this is the market this is it this is
the big leagues America and in America
to be in the 1% for all you math people
business that's very hard that's the
best the entry level is making four
hundred thousand dollars a year and yet
we're in this place where it's like
Billy or bust like people try to like
like we've got three guys for every
Instagram and uber and slack there's
eight billion [ __ ] and yet that's what
the barometer is and what it's doing is
it's making everybody try to build those
things when there's people in here that
can actually build a business that gets
them four hundred thousand dollars a
year by being the CEO and the
distributions at the end of the year
we're making a big mistake so um you
know I feel like when I'm done by the
Jets in 20 years this an ad I'm gonna
build a self-awareness Institute or
something hopefully science will kind of
I don't know I gotta I gotta find my
kind of compliment partner that
understands the things that I know know
but in my heart right here right in here
I know that I just need the nerd to tell
me this is the deal I'm like that's
right but there's this miss I need more
grounded stuff but I know that
self-awareness is the thing it's the
thing because let me explain to you what
happens with self-awareness when you've
got it at an extreme level you start the
process of being internally happy
because what self-awareness allows you
to do is to accept your shortcomings and
focus on your strengths and what it does
is allows you to navigate other people
you know what else happens with
self-awareness you start developing
empathy and all the other things around
it gratitude and all of a sudden you
know what else happens
people stop letting you down do you know
that nobody can let me down
I get it I've empathy I've
self-awareness I get it
like Jab Jab Jab right hook right my
last book give give give ask too many
people read it 14 times and think it
says give give give take or get no no
ask I just went through this book tour
the way I just launched it on Tuesday
the way I roll the week before I go into
full sales mode I hit up everybody and
say you
Oh homie I've done some good [ __ ] for
you and in detail no bull [ __ ] email
but this week and the individual that I
made a million dollars by getting them
into his angel deal that's sold that
they would have never gotten into that
they called me and begged me to get into
and I got them into but three books I
don't feel like that was a good exchange
for all the other things I did and you
would be stunned how much it doesn't
even register as a negative because I
get it he didn't you know didn't put the
pieces together it's okay and so
self-awareness telling you guys stop
lying to yourselves it's the single
greatest mistake oh oh thank you for
saying that I'll help that guy forty
more times I look at as a net human
thing maybe Sally suck [ __ ] but Ricky's
better and net net it's even so I'm
never I don't hold grudges I don't get
sad I'm like Zen doubt about it like
even my own well-being
I love capitalism and market dynamics so
much that if I deserve to go out of
business I deserved to get a business do
you know I'm spending the most time on
right now with my old white male friends
all these sixteen seventy year olds that
think they're capitalists and they're
Americans and this and that and what
they want to do is support a Republican
to do laws that will let them save and
hold on to more of their money I think
they're [ __ ] losers nobody saves IBM
or BMW there's no laws that just because
you were a good business for thirty
years
this presidents going to save you yet
these high net worth individuals want
laws to save them because they're old
and tired and they want to be on yachts
[ __ ] you keep working let's go with you
and the lady behind you in the new and
then okay to that guy and then we'll
wrap yep Mike location location
Chattanooga office yes yes and I'm just
wondering what have you learned what
have you gotten out of that office that
he wouldn't have gotten out of New York
around nothing yet
it's nine months old but I'm starting to
see the early stages of my executives
they're starting to understand what it's
like to make twenty seven thousand
dollars a year have three kids and shop
at downer Dollar General every day got
it like all of a sudden the big ideas
aren't like hey let's take our customers
and put them an uber with freshly
squeezed juice all of a sudden they
become much more practical out of that
office to make people buy [ __ ] got it hi
what's your name Jean amazing I will go
to the ends of the earth to promote my
clients effectively that I am pretty
terrible at self promoting interesting
oh yes um I think the best thing is
really trying to reverse engineer why
you're not good at it so I mean I don't
know if you want to get that real and
say it out loud in front of all these
people I'm more than happy to deal with
you for five minutes
ad hoc one day this summer but it's
trying to understand whether it's your
own confidence do you not think you
deserve it yet because you're early in
your career look at me I might be the
best at it I didn't start it until I was
34 years old after 12 years of building
an actual business that I think then I
had the intent I had the ability or the
audacity to go out and say hey look at
me
I did something I didn't so you're
you're very young so maybe maybe you
think it's that it's first unlocking why
next understanding do you actually need
it so nobody mean the Nike CEO isn't
good at self-promotion they just make
great [ __ ] product there's you know I
think there's a bad conversation that
all CEOs or it's really great to be like
this and that it helps your business
there's way more businesses making way
more money where you have no idea who
the CEO is then there are the
alternative so I wouldn't get so caught
up Stewart Butterfield isn't crushing
the personal brand
but slacks doing just okay so I think
first you have to decide if you have to
do that if you aspire to do that you've
got to go inside and figure out what's
held you back does that make sense I
think too many people like you need to
build your brand I'll bring you new
clients you know what brings you way
more clients you know what brings
vaynermedia way more clients than Gary
self-promoting doing great [ __ ] work
and then them telling other people to
hire us go figure
cool you're welcome this gentleman right
here
and then I'll go to the back you got it
it's not your your time you show where's
jack
yep so I actually bought when first of
all wine 101 or TV last week
thank you brother my question is anyone
who's watched the other video I will
understand you are like a master
communication okay appreciate from your
employees so the question is who are
some other business Metta women who you
think are kind masters of communication
because we've been able to see how far
that goes and solving problems moving
the ball for truth is I don't know you
know really I don't like I don't mind
standing up here and answering I don't
know when I don't I don't back to back
to that lovely lady's question like I
spend no time trying to figure out what
Tony Hsieh or Richard Branson or sucks
or Travis or doing I just don't have
time but I the only thing I do is
consume people so if I hear about them
I'm hearing the headlines about those
people but I know what the headlines say
about me so I know there's a you know
different you know when Business
Insider's trying to get links that's
what the headline is right so truth is I
don't know I can tell you this Tony
Hsieh is wildly famous for company
culture he's a horrible internal
communicator it's quite introverted he
understands the value of it he's built
brand around it he's a great dude he's
massively awkward one on one like his
daily be that you know the daily che
looks very different than what you've
been watching what I've been putting out
I'm in the business of five minute
one-on-one meetings because I you I mean
look at the last one we just have I
promise you that was good [ __ ] advice
without being cold and knowing nothing
can you imagine if she work for me for
18 months and I know that she loves golf
and that she's great with her sister and
she did great on the Budweiser account
but not as good on
broca's Hasbro didn't like when I have
context I own five minutes might be too
much for me to be able to do my thing
got it let's run them back to Mike jump
in the back you can get that brand you
know what I mean so I don't know I I you
know I always seem that any company that
has great culture for real not publicly
but for real probably has somebody at
the top that's really good at it or
understands it and empowers his or her
HR departments and people for example
vaynermedia we're about to announce a
new position chief heart officer that's
who's sitting over our HR but the reason
we have such great HR is almost
everybody that works for Vayner is an
Account Supervisor and in HR a creative
director and an HR a lot of people go to
different people in my company for HR
usually senior people in departments
that aren't even in HR my man Tom you're
welcome yes I've been following the
software's path yes you're on this
mission yes do you have vision new
officer vision or what you see be on
Twitter and be on Facebook the truth is
I don't predict you know so I don't have
an answer for that
you know I'm a counter-puncher I'm
reacting I'm day trading I don't know
what's being invented I don't know the
two girls at UCLA right now inventing
the next thing what I do what I can tell
you is I'm always keeping tabs at things
at all times so right now on my tab list
is peach is anchor is musically is
after-school so those are four platforms
that I'm paying close attention to I've
also got a quarter of an eye on some
things that are more mature that with a
tweak or two could be much bigger
SoundCloud kik Wattpad so those are
seven things stocks that I'm watching
that potentially could be interesting to
me but I can tell you they're very
easily become sound close you know they
those companies can easily become social
code and plurk and all these other
things that have happened through the
years so I wouldn't I don't talk about
them publicly what I usually do is I'll
put it into an answer of daily fee or
askgaryvee I'll write one meet
article about my intuition on him I'll
answer you right now and I know D Rox
recording it so I'll have the copy but I
don't do what I did with snapchat on in
January first where I come out and say
boom bye
these are things on the watch list and
the truth is my watch list very rarely
has brought something to buy because
there's only a couple things to buy
you know you I mean guys YouTube
LinkedIn Facebook I mean like there's
like eight of them Instagram like like
how why does everybody think they're
going to build the next [ __ ] snapchat
there's like eight of them in 12 years
there's been eight started since I
started this talk mark you talk about
self-aware yes what are you going to
become self-aware digest I doubt that my
man how about that I think I think look
some people are lucky enough that they
stumble into a miracle in the sixth
round and good stuff happens and others
don't
so if somebody gets hurt first but you
know what I mean I mean like look let's
not get too crazy on this Patriots
dynasty if it was so mastermind you know
then they would have taken the guy in
the first round not the sixth so there's
a lot of sports that's not business
that guy got it it's a really good idea
actually I was about to get nasty guys
thank you so much for having me I wish
you well